[Music]
it is seven o'clock which means you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster today marks a year
since the prime minister's first state
home message as the country was plunged
into lockdown
but now a warning that we'll be feeling
the impact
coronavirus for at least a decade also
this morning reports that care workers
will be required by law to have a covert
jag
and a talk of a hefty fine if we happen
to venture abroad
plenty then to discuss with the health
secretary matt hancock in just a few
minutes time
but also this morning from the stage
to the front line we'll be speaking to
the people who've changed careers to
help the nhs
over the last year in lockdown and also
on the show
i will be chatting to this fantastic 11
year old vlad
who spent the whole year camping in his
back garden
to raise money for his local hospice all
in memory
of his next-door neighbor that's coming
your way at quarter to 10
on this tuesday the 23rd of march
12 months like no other a minute silence
at midday candles on
doorsteps somber ceremonies to mark one
year
since the first national lockdown the
prime minister calls
for a day for reflection
the consequences of codex a warning that
we could continue to feel the impact of
the pandemic for a decade
why taking off could land you in trouble
a five thousand pound fine for anyone
traveling abroad
without a good excuse
a year she won't remember one her
parents will never forget
sky news meets the lockdown baby who has
only lived
in the shadow of the pandemic
supermarket shooting a police officer
among 10 people
killed as a gunman opens fire in the u.s
state of colorado
facing a vote of no confidence
scotland's first minister remains
under pressure as a final report into
the alexander inquiry
is due to be published later today
some sunny spells for eastern parts
today but elsewhere rather
cloudy with some rain heading in from
the west and that sets us up for
an unsettled few days of weather
morning all it has been 12 months since
the prime minister's
state-home tv address to the nation
boris johnson says the past year has
been one of the most
difficult in the country's history well
today along with the charity marie curie
he's calling for a
day of reflection marked by a minute
silence at noon
along with candles on doorsteps at 8pm
but even with covert cases and deaths
continuing to decline there's a warning
that the social and economic impact from
the pandemic could be with us
for more than a decade to come sky's
laura bunduck has our first report
from this evening i must give the
british people a very simple
instruction you must stay at home
it was the speech that changed
everything
no prime minister wants to enact
measures
like this i know the damage that this
disruption is doing
and will do to people's lives to their
businesses
and to their jobs one year ago the
country commanded
into lockdown it brought panic
eerie emptiness and deep personal grief
he had a great sense of fun and a great
sense of humor
he loved to sing songs and yeah real
memories of him singing to them
it was lovely rachel pennant's dad cliff
died last april he was in a care home
and caught covered i used to watch the
news in the
evening and i would see the numbers
going up
and i would always think i would take
one off
and think that one was my dad
it has been an unimaginable year for us
all
care homes and hospitals found
themselves in need
with shortages of ppe three of these
words no
all homes became schools and offices
you have no authority here jackie weaver
no authority
at all as we all got to grips with
remote working
and although distance from each other
communities felt closer
but constant reminders too no one was
immune from
covid not even the prime minister
126 000 people have lost their lives
the numbers are still rising
but so is hope
the last year will affect us all for
years to come
the impacts of cover 19 are going to
play out
over a much longer period and this is
because things like the social
the economic and the cultural impacts
will
will play out and cast a long shadow
into the coming decade
as we look back on the last year a
minute silence at midday and candles on
doorsteps
whatever our faith or philosophy may be
let us take a moment together to
remember those
who have been lost to give thanks
for their lives and to acknowledge the
inexpressible pain of partying
it's a pain still being felt by many
what i'll be doing is i'll be looking
back um but i'll be trying to remember
some of the hopeful things of the past
year as well
because um i think we're all looking
forward to moving on
i will be remembering but i will be
remembering
with hope too laura bundock sky news
hodaston in hertfordshire
very pleased to see the health secretary
matt hancock joins us once again
on the program mr hancock as always good
to see you um good morning
good morning to you a year on um from
the first lockdown
a day of reflection i wonder how you'll
be spending it
well i'll be uh i'll be working mostly
i'll be working on the vaccine rollout
and trying to get us out of this
and that's the that's what i spend all
my waking hours
on at the moment i thought that was a
very moving uh
a very moving package that you just
shown
and i think a lot of people will be will
be feeling
the same as the emotions expressed in it
both by
his royal highness the prince charles
and also by
the members of the public explaining
that this has been an incredibly
difficult year
and probably the hardest year in a
generation
and yet we all search for hope as well
don't we
and the the hope is that we now
have a root out of this and that root is
possible because of the
the wonders of science and the scale of
the vaccination program
the wonders of science is a very good
way of putting it but on the
the vaccination root out of this reports
this morning
that the government that you in fact and
the prime minister have agreed to a
change in the law
that would compel people working in in
care homes to have a vaccine is that
accurate
well no decisions have been taken as you
know we have a
a task force looking at the question of
certification of whether there's things
that you need to be able to show that
you've had a vaccine or indeed a test in
order to be able to do
um that looks both at the quite these
questions around international travel
but is also looking at the question
of whether in order to be able to care
for people
professionally um then you ought to have
protected yourself
so that you can't infect others this is
something that happens already
for instance doctors have to have the
hepatitis b
vaccine and it's clearly something that
has
important moral questions on on both
sides so it is something that we're
looking at but it
but no decisions have yet been taken
important moral questions and important
legal questions as well i mean
you would presumably expect a decision
such as this
to be challenged in the court so on that
basis would you
are you currently looking at vaccination
not simply of those who work in care
homes but perhaps
mandatory vaccination for as you put up
just a moment ago people working
in care people caring which could
generally apply to quite a lot of people
in the health service as well
well as i say this already is the case
in terms of hepatitis b
in the nhs for doctors and
so there is a clear precedent for
this proposition at the moment what
we're looking at is
for those who work in care homes elderly
care homes
on the grounds that they are the most
vulnerable to this disease that's why
they were in
the very first cohort of the groups to
be vaccinated
um and um it is a and it's something
that some care homes have actually
called for
because it would require a change in the
law through secondary legislation
and and therefore i entirely understand
why
why some care homes wanting to take that
duty of care
over those who are who are in that home
of the
for the residents um are are keen for us
to be able to take this step
um to so that so that they can uh
require uh people who who could
otherwise pass on the virus to
to take the vaccine there is of course a
fairly big question that follows all of
this that if we are actively considering
mandatory vaccination if you want to
work in a care setting
could we consider mandatory vaccination
more generally
in the public in the population at large
i mean the jcvi
um modelling showed us i think it was in
the tail end of the tail end of last
week
the ideal percentage targets for
vaccination and we're looking at 75
coverage in in under 50s when when we
get to that stage that is a big
target now if we're not coming close to
that target are there circumstances in
which
you could see mandatory vaccination for
people under the age of 50.
no we've ruled that out for the general
population and there's a difference
which is if you you know if you as a
profession care for people and are
therefore in very close contact with
them
then that is that is different to the
the general population
um and um you know on these percentages
they are important
the the uptake amongst the
groups that we're vaccinating is
unbelievably high
over 95 percent now in
the most elderly groups
and for care home workers where it is a
bit lower it is now
greater than three quarters uh in
elderly care homes
amongst staff who've been vaccinated
amongst residents is over 90 percent
so these take a break
sorry we've got so much to get through
and i think the point in terms of
vaccinations and care homes has been
made
but there will be people looking at the
the the rate of progress
that we are making in terms of
vaccinations and wondering why the
government is bringing forward
you know fines of 5 000 pounds for
people
who head abroad without good excuse i
mean it does seem
that the government this morning is
basically saying look
until the very earliest july summer is
cancelled
if you're looking to go abroad at the
very least
no i think it's quite important to clear
this one up um
the the the questions of whether people
will be able to
travel abroad this summer are going to
be
addressed by the global travel task
force which is reporting around
the 12th of april so middle of next
month
um the roadmap sets out that the
earliest date
by which we will um allow for
international travel without one of them
uh
clear excuses reasons that you need now
um is the 17th of may that has not
changed
the way we're putting that into law is
as part of these roadmap regulations
that we voted on on thursday
and they come to an end as a whole at
the
end of june but that doesn't change the
timings for these questions on
international travel now having said all
of that
it is now too early to know where that
the global travel task force will come
out and know what the decision will be
for the 17th of may and the reason for
that
is that we are seeing this
third wave rising in some parts of
europe
and we're also seeing new variants
and it is very important that we protect
the progress that we've been able to
make
uh here in the uk where we have we're
now on the prime minister yesterday i
mean he was talking about a third wave
you know
developing in europe and and washing up
on our shores when a wave hits our
european friends he said you know
it ends up in our shows it seems a
slightly strange way of talking about
it given that this third wave if you
want to call it that in europe emerged
you know
not far from where i'm standing in kent
we exported it
to the european union well it shows what
an international challenge this
this is and what we have to do
uh is all work as much as we can
together
but it also shows why we're being
cautious on international travel because
you know we've seen that
that these waves come before we saw
you know the first and then the second
and they both ended up here
the the action that you took most
recently on our borders was
in your own words to prevent new
variants from arriving here to prevent
cases coming to the united kingdom why
should we be worried in any way
about a third wave happening on the
continent giving the changes that you've
made
well we should be concerned because we
have seen the
impact before and the
the question that your system
we did absolutely but there's also we
also have a
um a desire if if possible if it's safe
to do so
to open up international travel of
course people want i understand people
want a
summer holiday abroad if it's safe and
we've got to make that decision on on
whether it's safe and we'll do that
according to the timetable that's set
out in
the roadmap now the the
the good news is that thankfully we have
this
uh very significant vaccine rollout here
we've got
we you know yesterday we we saw the
30 millionth vaccine overall
both first and second doses combined and
and this this vaccine program is clearly
saving lives here but we need to make
sure that
that we protect that rollout from the
concerns that might come from new
variants and we need to
work on understanding more okay
if if you want to if you're if you're
wanting to take credit for the
vaccination program
and i i understand when you do then you
have to at some point
accept some of the criticism that is
laid at the door we are a year on
from the first lockdown and according to
the johns hopkins tracking
we are fifth in total deaths sixth in
deaths
per hundred thousand sixth and deaths
per population
why has that happened why in terms of
mortality
compared to other countries have we done
so poorly
well the that's a very important
question and it's one that
it'll be the right time to assess that
in the future
but now the right task is to
spend all of our energies on so
might be on its way here when is the
appropriate time
you know if things go badly we could
still be in this
same time next year things go
catastrophically we could still be in
this in some form
at which point you could again say look
we're still in the middle of it we're
still dealing with it
you've been in charge of our pandemic
response you personally
must have an idea why we are sixth in
the world
in deaths uh per capita
well i think that i i think the point
that you make is an important one
because
um it's trying to get this country
out of this pandemic that is what i
spend all of my time on
and vital and central to that task
is constantly to learn about what has
worked well
and what we need to do better and
differently and we've done that
forum for that presumably would be an
independent inquiry i'm not going to
waste your time on mine
by asking for you to to promise that one
will be set up straight away
but perhaps on today of all days you
could promise you could reiterate in
fact the promise
that the prime minister made in july of
last year that there will be a full
inquiry as soon as possible
yes i i think it of course the prime
minister set out that there needs to be
all of these questions and i think
that's totally reasonable not least
because we need
permanently in future permanently to be
ready for
another pandemic um that is a
that is a fact of life and it's
something that we need to be
uh prepared for and we need to make sure
that all of the
learnings and all of the scientific
improvements we've been talking about
are are understood and that we
are properly ready but
the um but you know what we need to do
right now is learn those lessons in
practice
to make sure that the actions that we
take now
are guided by our best understanding of
this virus
and our best understanding of the of the
pandemic and we've done that throughout
and um you know that has led to
um the road map with its cautious
but i very much hope irreversible uh
timetable
um and you know we get people saying
can't you go faster and
can't you open up international travel
you know more easily
and and also some people saying can't
you go slower but i think the va
you know the general bulk of the
population most people
think that this is at about the right
pace
and the scientists the best science
thinks that this is at about the right
pace but we'll keep monitoring the data
to make sure that it's safe to take each
step and that you know that's at the
at the core that builds on learning you
know as much as we can
and uh and trying to make the very best
judgments in what are very
difficult circumstances yeah they are
they are they are very they are very
difficult
circumstances indeed we do need to let
you go minister very conscious of the
time uh that you need to spend with
other interviews this morning so thanks
very much for being with us
thanks for having me on uh tom raynor
was of course uh listening to the health
secretary this morning
morning tom um just in terms of that
which we were hearing laterally look i
mean i think i think
from from the health secretary i think
that's as far as i've actually heard him
go
in terms of answering the big question
why in terms of total deaths why in
terms of death per capita have we
have we done so badly he he he accepts
that this is a question that needs
answering
yes he does but what he didn't do is say
when that
question should be answered and of
course that's something that the
opposition are pushing hard for to have
a public inquiry to have a date set in
so that lessons can be learned
but there was yes you're right an
acknowledgement that there is
a question to be answered and you know
no doubt that forms part of the
reflections that will go on today 12
months in
but i thought two other things stood out
neil in that interview first on this
question of whether or not care home
workers
will be required to be vaccinated uh
matt hancock said there was
no decisions taken yet despite reports
in this morning's newspapers that such
decisions
had been endorsed by him and the prime
minister but he did say
that there is a task force looking at
the question of certification now this
is really important because
the government have been very keen to
avoid the idea of vaccine passports
but they have been keen uh to suggest
that there might be some form of
certificate which could either prove
a vaccine or a negative test
an indication there i think that that is
what we potentially are going to be
looking at in the care home setting and
one final point neil
about the issue of global travel reports
today that the changes in health
regulations would
put back the possibility of
international travel well they do in
terms of the
legal regulations but matt hancock
insisting that wouldn't necessarily
impact
the dates in the roadmap which say that
it could be as early as may
the 17th tom thanks very much indeed
and we will have special coverage of
that one minute
silence to remember those who died
during the pandemic that's here on sky
news
from midday and a little later dammit
mirnah
is going to be hosting a two-hour
special program at looking back on a
year
that no one could have imagined that is
now the norm that's kobe crisis one year
at seven o'clock tonight
uh but let's bring you the latest
monthly data for employment
and economic activity now uh sky's
business correspondent helen ann smith
is
in the newsroom with all the details
how's it looking helen
good morning well the unemployment
figures up until this month are actually
very slightly improved um on what they
were
last month so we get a total now from
the office for national statistics for
the number of people
who are no longer on the payroll uh
since the beginning of the pandemic and
that's ever so slightly down
693 000 fewer people
are on the payroll now than they were
pre-pandemic that's
roughly just under 70 000 fewer than we
saw
last month a similar trend too in the
unemployment rate
uh the three months last quarter it
stood at 5.1 percent
at this quarter down to five percent so
small fractional
fractional improvements one detail
that's worth pointing out the ons have
done some analysis about
who are losing these jobs and they've
actually found that it's the under 25s
that are
really adversely particularly affected
by all this
60 of that big number were people under
the age of 25.
now you might ask that given the fact
we're in a big lockdown why these
figures
are slightly improving it might reflect
growing confidence because of the
vaccine it might reflect
reflect the fact that businesses are
adapting slightly and of course it
reflects again
the fact that that furlough scheme the
support schemes are continuing
uh they're going to go up until
september we may see a little more
unemployment once they're over but for
now they're really keeping some of those
cracks plastered over
helena thank you now ten people
including a police officer have been
killed after a gunman opened fire in a
supermarket in the u.s state of colorado
authorities confirmed the suspect was
detained and that there is no ongoing
threat to the public
sky's u.s correspondent greg milam has
the detail
we have multiple calls coming from
inside of people that have
barricaded themselves inside our shooter
he's inside he just shot at us twice
the call started just after lunchtime a
man with a rifle
at a supermarket and what america's seen
so many times before
happening all over again
[Music]
the mass shooting this time at the
king's super in boulder in colorado
more victims of america's epidemic of
gun violence
outside there was a massive police
response many of those who were inside
ran for their lives we just kept going
we just ran and there was somebody
laying in the road
and i tried to run towards him and
nicholas pulled me away
and that we have to go and we just ran
and hid behind the buildings on the end
over here
as the news cameras caught customers
being guided to safety by police
they also captured the suspected gunman
being led away
an apparent injury to his leg there is
no word yet
on any motivation for the shooting among
those who died was police officer eric
talley
he'd been the first to arrive on the
scene
my heart goes out to the victims
of this incident
and i'm grateful to for the police
officers that responded and i am so
sorry
about the loss of officer tally
many who were inside the supermarket had
come for covet vaccinations at its
pharmacy
the pandemic may have replaced news of
mass shootings on the screens of
americans but
like so many places colorado has seen
its share of gun violence
to columbine high school and the cinema
in aurora
we now add this to a depressing roll
call of murder
that this country for all the talk of
gun control is unwilling
or unable to confront greg milam sky
news
let's take a look at a few of the other
stories at making the news this morning
and a final report into how the scottish
government mishandled complaints against
the former first minister alex salmond
will be released later this morning the
findings from msps on the harassment
complaints committee
comes a day after the first minister was
cleared of breaching
the ministerial code that report
described some of nicolas sturgeon's
some aspects of nicolas sturgeon's
behaviour as regrettable even naive
but concluded that she had not misled
parliament
germany is extending its lockdown until
april the 18th
and the public are advised to stay at
home for five days over the easter
holidays to try to break a third wave of
the kovid 19 pandemic
german authorities also agreed on a
blanket requirement for travellers to be
tested for covert 19
before boarding a flight to germany
nhs england says using dexamethasone to
treat coronavare's patients may have
saved
a million lives around the world the
steroid was found to reduce covert
related deaths
nine months ago following a clinical
trial at oxford university
around 22 000 deaths are said to have
been prevented with its use
in the uk alone
new figures show that only half of gp
appointments are now conducted face to
face
it's been warned that the move to video
and phone consults and booking
appointments online
means that some people are unable to
access care
a seal living in the river thames has
had to be put down
after being attacked by a dog had been
named
freddie mercury and had become hugely
popular with residents of hammersmith in
west london
entertaining people on the banks of the
river but after being taken to south
essex wildlife hospital
he died after sustained see sustaining
broken bones in the attack
now while today marks one year since the
uk first entered lockdown
for jenny burr it is also her daughter
flora's
first birthday on march 17 last year
jenny was admitted to hospital while
pregnant suspected of having covered 19
but was discharged with a negative test
just
six days later though she was back in
hospital celebrating flora's birth
while the prime minister announced a
national lockdown
sky's becky johnson has been meeting the
family
flora is our original lockdown baby she
was march the 23rd
who knew that that was what was going to
happen uh her being born and us going
into lockdown
still in hospital with her newborn
daughter just hours
old janie heard the news from this
evening i must give the british people a
very simple
instruction you must stay at home
[Music]
as they introduced flora to her brothers
and the weeks went by
little did they know she'd reach her
first birthday
with normal life still yet to resume
what a year what a year for everyone
what a year
like for flora for
families everyone who's been working so
hard
like people who've died people who've
lost
people what an absolute crazy year
for flora's parents the silver lining of
lockdown has been the time they've had
at home in oxford together
as a family but as an intensive care
nurse
janie decided to cut her maternity leave
short
to help her colleagues in london who
were under enormous pressure during the
second wave of the virus
it was really hard work and it was
really hard saying goodbye to the kids
for a couple of three three nights each
week um
but it was also yeah just
something that had like i felt like i
needed to do at the time
at home it's been a year of highs and
lows
meetings with grandparents have been
fleeting
let's give her class some water and
there are so many family and friends
who've missed out on precious moments
during flora's first year
it took a long time for her to actually
meet them and then she hasn't really
seen much more of them
um so that is is sad um
and pete has really brought the brunt of
it working from home
see if you can climb up again like so
many parents pete has had to learn
quickly how to balance work and family
life
spending a year at home has been a
challenge
not much space to have three kids
milling around all the time so lots of
calls with uh albie on my knee or other
children on my knee
twelve months on from the first lockdown
there is now hope at least
that the end is in sight and for flora
it's onwards and upwards
after a year she won't remember but her
parents
will never forget becky johnson sky news
in oxford
brilliantly story that let's bring in
isabelle and see how the weather is
looking today morning is
we were talking about it yesterday that
passed by the international space
station over the uk
clear sky skies in london last night it
was absolutely stunning we've got a few
more days where we might be
able to see in the evenings how the sky
is looking
ugh the weather's changing now so very
different actually a lot more cloud in
the sky i'm not
not to say there won't be some breaks
because we've got quite a sort of mobile
weather pattern fronts coming from west
to east in between hopefully some
clearer skies not just for the southeast
but for other parts as well so
i'll keep you updated but let's take a
look at the big picture
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
so we had high pressure yesterday across
the southeast temperatures reached 15
degrees in london
16 celsius actually in aberdeen
yesterday and there was some really
quite nice sunshine
the high that's been giving the dry
weather though is gradually slipping
away into the near continents allowing
fronts to come in from the northwest
the changes are underway in fact there's
fairly extensive cloud cover across many
western areas today with
strengthening winds and rain will be
gradually pushing in from the west
across
ireland and eventually into northern
ireland and western scotland this
afternoon
other areas hopefully seeing some sunny
break such i think the best in the south
east eastern scotland also
favored quite well temperatures in the
sunnier spots up to about 14
or 15. but the cloud extensive tonight
across central and southern areas with a
little bit of drizzly rain
and then tomorrow showers packing to the
north
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
as well thank you the uk marks a year
since the first lockdown today with a
minute silence and
candles and doorsteps earlier on the
program
matt hancock said it had been one of the
hardest years in a generation i asked
the health secretary
why the country had one of the worst
covert death rates per capita
anywhere in the world that's a very
important question
and it's one that it'll be the right
time to
assess that in the future i i think the
point that you make is an important one
because
um it's trying to get this country
out of this pandemic that is what i
spend all of my time on
and vital and central to that task
is constantly to learn about what has
worked well
and what we need to do better and
differently
and the health secretary there let's
speak once again to callum semple
professor of
outbreak medicine at the university of
liverpool and a member of sage
nerve type that group which provides
ministers and officials with
evidence-based scientific advice
professor great to see you this morning
um
a year on from the uh from the first
moments of lockdown
what would you have done differently in
those in those early stages
well as you know we're not we're not
speaking here about policy commentary
that's
a given for an interview like this but
in my
personal capacity the things that i
reflect on
which uh and i wasn't a member of sage
right at the start
i don't i i really appreciate how
infectious this virus was
that was that was one aspect which i'll
put my hands up when i got wrong
the the virus undoubtedly is uh
infectious in close quarters
uh by respiratory aerosol and droplet in
in close quarters and that's one of the
aspects that
i certainly didn't get right why was
that
i mean there were there was of course
everyone was struggling to get to grips
with
you know of course a a novel coronavirus
but it
we were looking abroad at places like
italy we were looking at hospitals
filling up
there were any number of scientific
questions but we were
in essence at least in the early stages
were flailing around a little bit in the
darkness waiting for that
empirical evidence um
yes it's incredibly difficult i think
what we what
what is society we didn't appreciate and
what as a wider group of society we
didn't
quite a group of scientists we didn't
appreciate was that
the virus was going to move into the
country essentially through british
people returning from holidays
in italy spain and france
the assumption was that it'd be more
traditional long-distance foreign
travelers coming back in that would
bring the virus in
and we really hadn't hadn't predicted
that it was going to be the
the surge of our own people coming back
and i think that's what made it very
would have made it very difficult had
there been a decision to go into an
earlier lockdown what would you have
done with the 20 000
british tourists out doing skiing and
having holidays at that time
you couldn't left them out there and
there simply wasn't the concept
of quarantine that would have been
acceptable on such a massive scale at
that point
even even quarantining a small number of
people coming off the cruise ships
was quite a logistical challenge at that
point society just wasn't really ready
for that
i as you said before professor of course
you're not here to defend policy
uh policy decisions taken by the
government that's not your job but it
it is a curious one i just wonder from a
personal perspective as someone who
wasn't involved in sage in the early
days is now
one of those who's providing advice how
difficult is it
for someone like you who is a who is a
scientist who is a scientist who views
things in in perhaps in purely
scientific terms
when we're dealing with a pandemic where
there is this intersection between
you know economic effects and health
effects
it must be quite strange to be operating
in these circumstances
it is we do bring best science as far as
we can where the evidence exists
to committees but all of us are fathers
and brothers or sisters
and we've all been living this as well
so it's not that we work
in complete isolation from the reality
of the clinical environment or the
social environment
or the effect it's having on our friends
and families so so there is
certainly a human element there is a
degree of common sense
in what we're doing so it's not just a
purely ethereal scientific process
that's going on here
no of course of course just one final
question professor um we are seeing
um the kent variant b117 running rampant
in parts of europe
certainly looks to be taking taking
control in the united states
given that it emerged here given that
there must be some kind of latent
resistance in the population
how concerned should we be about as the
prime minister put it
you know the wave of a third wave well
the effects washing up on our shores
well first of all the good news is that
the current vaccines all cover
the kent variant very well the concern
at present is that in countries where
there's less vaccination
and a very strong third wave at the
moment
that's the perfect breeding ground for
further variants of concern
so at this point britain the fuel has
got its act together
the concern is as this third wave is
going on elsewhere
that'll generate new variations but even
within britain
there is a likelihood of a third wave in
potentially july august time
when we do unlock society
but that third wave we would expect to
occur in people that are less
susceptible to very severe disease but
it's inevitable as we unlock
there will be a rise in cases but it's
the key here is
have we won the race to vaccinate the
most vulnerable
vulnerable members of society so that we
can keep society open this time and
get the economy back on the road one way
or another
we will find out in the not too distant
future professor callum simple great to
see you again
thanks for joining us
now uh change of tack authorities in
australia have issued more
flood warnings and evacuation orders
after a severe deluge
forced more than 18 000 people to leave
their homes
officials in new south wales for the
situation will
worsen in the coming days as the heavy
rain continues to fall
david richardson reports
paul luckman moved from liverpool to
sunny australia
eight years ago with his family now
everything
he owns is underwater it's probably gone
up about 150 mil inside the house
from the backyard to the house is
probably about three to four meters and
that come up in 24 hours
his street has flooded before because it
backs onto a small creek
he never expected it to become a giant
lake
well you watched it growing as you were
moving the furniture out
so yes it was let's get it out real
quick
it did slow we had time to get
everything out and lock it up and
sandbag it
nine days of constant rain and it shows
no sign of stopping
more than eighteen thousand people have
been forced to leave their homes
and more are set to follow
what you're seeing here is just a tiny
fraction
of all the land that is now underwater
in australia
we're now looking at an area that is
being hit by this flood
that is almost twice the size of the
united kingdom
road after road linking small riverside
villages
are closed making rescue attempts
virtually
impossible evacuations are being
conducted
by a string of rescue craft nicknamed
archangels
and helicopters winching people to
safety residents here
have never faced this before i've never
seen anything like this
and i've been speaking to people here
for days who've lived in this community
for decades
no one's seen it quite like this
and it's not likely to go away fast
i know
in this area the hawkesbury shire an
hour west of sydney
this flood is a 1 in 60 year event
across the rest of new south wales a 1
in 100 year disaster
10 million australians across 38
disaster zones
are living with some form of weather
warning and it was only a year ago
they faced the scourge of bushfires that
scorched earth
only making these floods so much worse
david richardson sky news sydney
australia
just a reminder that sky news is
launching the first daily prime time
news program dedicated to climate change
you can watch the daily climate show
every weekday at half past six in the
evening
at from wednesday the 7th of april
new statistics from the uk's fertility
regulator shows that
fertility treatment is less effective in
people from ethnic minority backgrounds
black patients were found to have
the lowest chance of success
um let's bring in dr christine acce a
consultant obstetrician and gynecologist
to get her expertise doctor great to
have you on the program this morning
and can we generalize in
any way as to why we are seeing such
significantly different rates of success
in terms of in terms of the
fertilization strategy
i think it's very hard to um there are
some
pieces of information that we do have so
for example we know that black women in
particular
are more likely to start ivf treatment
at a
later age compared to the rest of the
population
we know that black women who are seeking
either a donor egg or a donor sperm have
less options so only three percent of
the donut eggs
and three percent of the donor sperms
come from
a black donor we also know that black
women are
three times more likely to have a
condition
called fibroids that will impact on
their fertility
as well as having tubal damage but it's
much more complicated than that
we're also aware of maybe some cultural
stigma
that will prevent some women from
seeking help at an earlier age and
overall we need to remember
that black women particularly
unfortunately
suffer inequalities in their health
outcomes throughout their life course
this is just one iteration of that yeah
just just on that point doctor there was
a recent piece of research
talking about the experiences of black
women not in terms of fertility but kind
of the other end of the process when
when giving birth and the advice they
were given and plenty of anecdotal
evidence
suggesting that black women were not
being presented with a full range of
treatment options were being treated
differently
uh by doctors i mean it is there is the
potential for for this
for that to be having an effect the the
way in which black women are treated by
medical professionals for that to be
having an effect on fertility
i think we have to see it in the wider
context of
um the differences that
black in particular women but also
asian and women from other ethnic
minority backgrounds
experience whenever they are seeking
health care whether it
is at a much younger age so in
adolescence
if they are seeking help with fertility
or indeed when they are pregnant
what is particularly sad about this
specific statistic is that for a group
of women
they may not get pregnant at all and may
not have the joy of starting a family
if they wish to do so um and so this is
incredibly distressing for so many women
and indeed they're partners out there
doctor if i give you 20 seconds to speak
directly to
to black asian minority ethnic women who
are experiencing problems with fertility
what advice would you give them
the first thing is to seek help early
and to get the
information early i as part of the royal
college of obstetricians and the hfea
are now completely committed to engaging
with grassroots organizations and with
women to give the information that they
need
because essentially information is power
so get it early
daughter christine akechi great to have
you on the program this morning thanks
very much for being with us
so to come on breakfast this hour we'll
be hearing from the shadow
cabinet minister rachel reeves for
labour's view one year on from the first
long time
it's actually one of the most
fascinating things that the more i
looked into it the more i could see that
it really really wasn't some
western greeting and in fact chimps
shake hands
it's quite cute sometimes i actually
shake feet and they have very very
similar meanings
dr kat hobaiter who's a primatologist um
did an incredible study where she showed
that
they shake hands and it has a very
similar meaning so even after a fight
they'll often shake hands to make up
which is so very human as well isn't it
um and there are uncontacted tribes so
imagine people who have never met
the outside world um they know what a
handshake is so on first contact
a number of uncontacted tribes in new
guinea knew
instinctively what a handshake was
they'd already been doing them
so it turns out the handshake is
probably not just cultural it's probably
biological it's probably in our dna
especially if the chimps are also doing
it because of course they're our closest
relatives so actually the handshake is
is kind of it's not going anywhere as
far as i'm concerned
i think it's one of the things in our
repertoire i think one of the things
that we hate to think of
um as humans is that we're animals but
actually we are animals we haven't
evolved our way out of being animals and
communication chemically communication
via touch
is still incredibly important it's not
just about language but you know thank
god we do have language because it means
we've got that to fall back on and we're
not just out in the plains kind of just
relying on those things
but there are some incredible studies
that show how important handshakes are
um they have there's this thing called
chemo signals so chemical signals there
are these
incredible experiments where they put
gauze under people's armpits
they got them to watch uh sad films or
happy films and they
actually took that gauze to a different
group of people and the people were
accurately reflecting the emotion on
their faces
um and they actually were able to show
that when you shake hands you're more
likely to touch your face
unconsciously afterwards and take a
sniff
and so it turns out we really are
animals and that pancake is completely
functional i know it's kind of early in
the morning
but i i mean it's gross i know we think
it's gross but
it it's not actually that weird if you
think about it quite a few of us accept
that
sexual chemo signals pheromones exist so
why wouldn't other kinds of chemical
signals exist as well
[Music]
[Music]
did you know that air pollution isn't
just bad for the environment
it's bad for our health too
[Music]
i think more limited sunshine today the
best of the sunshine will be in the
southeast but for many there'll be a
good year to cloud around a freshening
breeze as well
will bring in some rain to western coast
and hills most persistent wet weather
though coming in across ireland
this afternoon you can see that band of
rain eventually reaching western
scotland
later on now because the winds pick up
that should help with
air pollution keeping it low for most
places maybe just moderate
near some busy roads or in urban centres
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
welcome back uh we are hoping to speak
to rachel reeves
labour's shadow chancellor of the duchy
of lancaster
in just a couple of minutes time uh
labor of course have been pushing
for that independent inquiry into uh
well the year that we have had since the
first lockdown
was announced uh let's
you've just had a little bit of isabel
lang why don't we have a double dose
whilst we wait uh
for ms reeves uh joining us from the
news well go on you take it away you can
tell us anything you like about the
weather whilst we wait for rachel
uh friday it looks very different neil i
mean goodness when we're out and about
on friday quite a wind chill and
cold enough air to bring some heavy snow
to the mountains of northern britain as
well
that's friday let's take a look at today
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
not too bad for many today in that
there'll be a lot of dry weather there
will be some sunshine around as well
particularly in the east
but we'll start to see changes from the
west as the front comes in that'll bring
in some rain
strong winds too for the north and west
and then that rain will tend to fizzle
as it moves its way southwards across us
during tomorrow but today at least some
sunny breaks developing after a bit of a
murky start i should think
quite optimistic for a while across the
southeast before it clouds over later
eastern scotland another favorite spot
for some sunny spells otherwise
as i said mostly dry mostly cloudy for
today
with the exception being ireland and
then later northern ireland and western
scotland
with rain to end the day there with
quite a strong wind as well and that
rain gradually topples its way down
into more central and southern parts by
around tomorrow morning
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
in the whirlwind of the early days of
the pandemic many expected lockdown to
cause
just a few weeks of disruption for
residents in one cheshire street
outdoor socially distanced fitness
classes while they were the way to pass
the time
and get through the ordeal from
freudsham our north of england
correspondent tom parmenter
sent this report
there was no manual for how to deal with
a pandemic
last march a virus was about to invade
all of our lives
and nobody really knew what to do huge
amount of shock
really i think we were all quite stunned
when we were first told to stay at home
the street dancing and coming out with
neighbours
helped to shield us from a lot from the
reality there was
a lot of dreadful stuff going on outside
that bubble
i've been to three funerals personally
and i think
certainly two two of those we've decided
that we'll come back
and meet together as a family in happier
times
there were the walks that we never knew
were there
emma's dad was one of the first to catch
covid
literally any control that you thought
you'd have
in a hospital situation or anything like
that before suddenly there was no rules
anymore that
sort of fit with you know expectations
of what was happening
he was on the severe shielding side of
things as well so how somebody with a
quarter of a lung has
come through this and survived it
removed to tell the tale i will never
know last week joanna swapped frodsham
for venice they've become very good at
passing the time
yeah it has become quite a bit of a
addictive addictive
yeah but they've missed their daughter
claire who is profoundly disabled
she's not spoken in 43 years
and they've only been allowed a few
visits to her specialist accommodation
it's bit hit or miss with the zoom you
know initially she didn't know
whether it was on the ceiling or whether
i was going through the door
um she could hear my voice but she
didn't know where the voice was coming
from
so it has been difficult it has been
difficult
the andersons have never spent so much
time together
homeschooling is thankfully over but
homeworking
will stay it's almost like the new topic
of conversations
have you had your job yet you know for
people money it's not beyond your job
you know what are you getting
all right it's just completely
incredible how things that were
completely alien a year ago were all
just part of your daily life now
this has changed people and what they
want from their lives
i want a simple life after this i have
lots of things i would not want to go
back to doing
people have realized that it's people
that matter
i think it brings out the better the
best of the british people
we always hear the negative sides but we
don't often hear
the positives nobody has the same story
but we've all shared what's happened tom
parmenter
sky news fraudsham in
uh cheshire a year on from the beginning
of at the start of uh first locked and
let's
once again talk to uh talk to tom i mean
the question is of course
if not now for a public inquiry then
when there's so many questions about why
we have such a death rate
yeah and the labour party have been
asking for that for some time but they
are really pushing that point
uh today because ministers are talking
about the need
to reflect on 12 months that has touched
absolutely everybody as you heard in
that report there
there is nobody who has not been
affected by this some
far worse uh than others kia starmer
today will be asking boris johnson to
set a date for that inquiry
and as you heard from matt hunker qualia
this hour they're not prepared to give
one
tom many thanks indeed stay we are come
back for the top of the eight o'clock
when we will have
much more a year on from the start of
long time